and again these classes are really
opportunities for yourself to come and
to say look I got a game I had an issue
with could you just go over it and the
first game lasted so long because
basically I had to fish very hard to get
a second score sheet thanks to Julian
for coming to the rescue where's my
glasses
okay so Julian there's the story what's
the what's the story of this game when
did you play it who's who what what the
nice tournament here at the club yeah
excellent strong master player you're
breaking into the expert ranks so okay
you so you're you're facing of an
opponent who's several hundred points
higher rated than you what was the
result of the game you don't have the
whole game
okay kudos all around nice to make a
draw against a much higher ranked player
and nice to be on the sunny side of it
yeah like you just smack in at the very
end and just manage to save your pitous
okay Julian with White Knight f3
reasonable opening move c5 e for it's
very interesting in the top-level chess
I'm thinking in terms at the top 10 top
20 of the world Vladimir Kramnik has
been playing Knight f3 is a near
religion on move one with the idea
playing C for D for g3 on move 2
depending upon how he plays his mood a
lot of efore players like to play
against all kinds of Defense's
especially and including the Sicilian
they don't really like playing against
'if I've be 45 it's a tough nut to crack
and well II 45 is just not bringing
white a great deal of success so I I
notice that in the top levels a lot of
players are adopting cram next move
Knight f3 and when their opponents play
move like see fie for example Alexander
Grisham likes to play see 596 and E 5 in
that move order 1 2 3 players change of
high e [ __ ] and it's their way of
getting the open Sicilian so
congratulations on setting the fashion
trend for the Magnus Carlson's of the
world really for six great d4c takes d4
Knight takes d4 knight c6 now the
Paulsen Sicilian which can transpose to
lots of other variations Shyvana guns
and what-have-you I happen to think
that the false in Sicilian this move
order for black is actually a very very
good variation of the Sicilian and it's
really not played that often it seems
like everybody and his brother likes to
play the night or they like to play the
dragon they like to play other forms of
the Sicilian that if you take a look for
example about Judith Polgara the
greatest female chess player ever in the
history she basically played it her
whole life she came into the world's top
ten a lot of players when they were
playing Judith knew that she was going
to play this particular position
prepared like hell for her and ended up
losing so it kind of goes to show that
this specific variation should not be
under grated today I would say Alexander
more Xebec Peters fiddler and others are
adopting this system and I remember of
course the famous kiss Parra Karpov
Kasparov games with night B 5 D 6 c4
Knight f6 Knight c3 a six-night a3 going
for a kind of Baroque see by Hedgehog
position and then Gasper off shut out
with a d5 move in a world championship
match and probably won one of the
greatest games ever played with the
black side so again this system with
knight c6 and e6 deserves a lot more
attention than it gets and I'm not too
sure why I play it with black and I've
done pretty well knight c6 Julian came
up with Bishop e2
huh okay
essentially in this position the main
moves are Knight c3 and c4 Bishop e2 is
not one of the main modes so after
Bishop e2 it's almost a hundred percent
for sure that you've thrown away any a
white opening advantage that you might
have had and your opponent can punish
your move order by playing Knight f6
saying gift me upon and you have to
decide what you're going to do the first
thing that you have to recognize is that
knight c6 b c6 e five losses upon i've
lost this pawn as white many many times
to two Knight takes c6 b take c6 e five
losses upon and I've lost the pawn as
white many times to create five check
well if I clean like though I've only
done that four times what am I going to
remember not to lose my pot so you can't
play a line with E 5 because Queen a5
check is going to cost you if you defend
the pawn with Knight c3 which would kind
of be a normal defense now comes Bishop
b4 now you got the same problem I want
to play Knight takes e4 now in this
position it's quite true that you can
play e5 but maybe you're not so very
happy there's a there's a pin here
that's rather annoying also the knight
could go here as well just equally and
the Queen on a5 and why it's already in
chess parlance sees the defensive
okay so I'll put it to you Julian how
did you intend to meet Knight f6
ah so you're wrong footed you a little
yeah and then in this position
well f3 does encourage black to start
thinking in terms of Bishop c5 or Queen
b6 controlling and this diagonal and and
if your Bishop was on f1 at this
position one of the moves you would
probably consider as Bishop d3 now let
your bishops on e - you're kind of
scratching your butt thinking here's the
like vision for me - maybe I should put
my okay
so then like 92 ePHI so now it kind of
looks a little bit like a French defense
where you you know you're a little bit
wrong-footed here you know you're in a
French defense with a pawn on e5
normally speaking your Bishop might be
on d3 here your pawns on e5 black has
ideas
you know if you go pardon me I should
have put the knight on f3 but the idea
is to trade bishops when you can go
Queen a5 Jack and so black is actually
doing pretty pretty good a main main
main line just a second just a second
here in this position main line where
are we that you're probably aware is
Knight b5 Knight f6 mm-hmm
now Bishop f4 is not anything special
Knight d6 check just loses a pawn after
trades in 94 so 90 Knight here is the
main move Bishop here is the main move
yeah so the main line for for white is
a3 Bishop takes Knight Knight takes d5
pawn takes pawn takes and black gives up
the two bishops accepts an isolated pawn
normal move is Bishop d3 normal move is
castles castles and normal move is 'if
I've okay so for example Judah not
Judith Bogart but Susan Polgar has
probably played this position ten times
or more in tournament games and she's
happy with blacks free play yeah so
again you know you compare this mainline
position that's been played umpteen
times versus your Bishop e2 and you're
really getting the feeling that you
slipped as early as move four okay here
here here here here here
oops disappear Bishop e2 so I'm I'm a
little surprised your opponent has very
experienced master didn't jump on you
with Knight f6 but instead played a move
that fits in pardon me
yeah fits into a lot of Paulsen
Cecilia's he plays the move Queen c7 one
of the ideas behind this move Queen c7
is black sometimes captures this Knight
and after the Queen is recaptured he
once provided that his g7 pawn dozen
he wants to play Bishop c5 and win a
tempo here it just so happens that
Knight f6 is a much superior move to
greens e7 so c4 probably a question mark
probably it's time for you to get out of
Dodge very quickly here after c4 Knight
of six you're in trouble again Knight c3
Bishop b4 okay your opponent erred okay
your opponent let you slip off the hook
so to speak he's supposed to capture
capture and play bishop here when again
if you look at the theory of this line
and again so many so many games black is
already considered to be not just okay
but he's gone from okay to being more
than okay like this position is actually
considered dangerous for you so
obviously your Queens attacked and you
got to decide d3 d2 d1 oh you can make
an argument for all all of these moves
so for example if you play queen d3 here
from blacks point of view this is good
this is good this is bad must do
something about this
so black oftentimes plays b6 and Bishop
b7 to try to tie you down the trade of
knights has meant that sometimes the
Queen can actually step to e5 and it's
not so easy for you to boot it out of he
5 like if you had a knight it'd be nice
but without the knight the Queen can
take up the central square you have to
decide well what exactly is my Queen
doing on
three like does it mean I should move to
g3 yeah well many times yeah yeah many
times
black does play this move H five so he
can play Knight g4 and as you just
pointed out correctly so that with the
combination of the bishop Queen Knight
that that looks pretty good
the other deeper question that you might
have is you've got this bishop on e to
how effective is that Bishop like in
other words where is it going that's
going to scare the bejesus out of black
yeah
yeah
right
right right and especially if you can
get an f4 g4 g5 Bishop f3 it all makes
perfect sense and I agree with you it
only it's it's just the specifics of the
position that your a for pawn is an
issue yeah and you're having to deal
with this efore point so in this
position if you Castle this should be
seven again you're thinking to yourself
well where is my light square Bishop
what is it doing that's really good and
along a lot of times if you get a
position where your Bishop comes to g5
it's not the biggest threat in the world
for you to threaten the tape to capture
the knight and double the pawns it's not
like black is especially concerned so
already the Paulsen Sicilian black is
supposed to be taking on d4 and playing
Bishop c5 right the fact that you've
just allowed him to do exactly that
makes it very very shocking to me that
that yeah that that black played Bishop
b4 when this gain of a tempo for free
plays itself right like just develop
your pieces with gain of tempo Knight
take Steve
so Bishop before question mark now you
seize this moment to play Knight b5 very
good and this totally changes the
position because now after a3 the bishop
went back and now it's you're in the
driver seat so you can play moves like
Bishop III so in this position you write
that you have castled and that black has
played Knight F
six so black played something else the
night of six so let's assume that black
played a six and you played 94 yeah it's
okay I'll do my best to castles Bishop
III so you get a standard Moroka C bind
slash hedgehog position except maybe
this knight on c6 is a little bit
misplaced at the moment and then indeed
it is okay you have played f3 and that's
a kind of a shame yeah you plate you you
got b4 in here so so you have played b4
okay so you got in b4 now and it looks
like he's played Bishop d7 and rook e8
which your bad moves and you've moved
your Queen to d2 and your rook on d1 and
then you had a very nice bind in this
exact position is funny but your whole
idea of Bishop e2 which wasn't good is
actually suddenly you know like a
peacock and what you should have done is
you should have just killed them like
you should have just gone g4 and g5 I
just like like nail him to a cross
that's it like a because the bishop on e
2 is actually in this position very very
finely placed to just go and get them
let's say black plays a little rook e8
not a good move not a bad move I'm just
as a demonstration of the type of a
killer attack you want you just just go
ahead and kill him like he's he's
misplaced his pieces and your next moves
are moves like f5 g6
you're just mangling him here b5 never
were
because the bishop is ideal and the
queen
everything is very passive so you're
just going to talk talk talk yeah so if
he plays in this position another move
let's say what else
what's another move 94 Bishop d4 d5
Bishop e3 you're just cementing your
control over squares yeah
nothing nothing happened there again b5
is really too slow you're going to play
g5 and when upon thank you for coming so
I think g4 is just a knockout below here
he's already in deep trouble b4 is wrong
b4 is wrong all you've done with this
move has weakened your knight Bishop e3
b4 is wrong Bishop d7 that's wrong yeah
but yeah yeah putting here that's not
where you where your need your Bishop to
be after this move b4 I start to think
of like how could I you de lo que so
let's let's make an obviously good move
rook d8 in many many cases in hedgehogs
you need to vacate the f8 square either
for your Bishop or sometimes for your
knight the rook d8 in this particular
case basically what I'm saying to you
I'm telegraphing my move I want to break
with d5 yeah okay Bishop f3 now why do
you regret playing the move b4
don't you like pawns I like pawns man at
the pawn on c4 you made the pond
you made the pawn on c4 vulnerable by
playing the move before
so you're just encouraging me to play
Knight e5 and gift me to pop the pop
yeah well for black that's a big success
considering that you know he was just
facing sudden death with g4 okay so more
or less you kind of just came to a
position that when Bishop d7 Queen d2
rook e8 rook on f1 or d1 rook on F to D
1 b6
king h1 f3 king h1 deep the you know
modern chess okay
tucking your king away Queen d7 now
black obviously suffers from the fact
that he doesn't understand that it's the
bishop that wants to be on b7
and it's the knight on c6 that wants to
agree on d7 so here what what's happened
is you have a nice comfortable edge and
space you've got control literally of
the center as well as the Queen side and
I think you have a considerable
advantage
okay excellent you took on c6 he took
with the bishop and b5 aha so your idea
was to target this fellow yeah and that
was pretty good
ooh
so you really were winning at that point
yeah like that like that that that's a
real take out so he did a quite a number
of things that were wrong and if we go
back to this moment
hedgehogs
can be terrible it's really worth
studying hedgehogs because I think their
their variation that if you understand
them well you can score a lot of points
with both both colors and your guide
will be Olfa Anderson
Olfa Anderson love to play the Hedgehog
and he did it extraordinarily well and
olfi in this position he would have
played against you Knight e5 yeah and so
his idea would be to put pressure on you
on your c4 point and his idea is he
wants to incur he wants to coax you bait
you if you will into playing f4 because
he reckons that he has to initiate
action very very quickly before you get
an overwhelming position like what you
got right and if you don't play f4 then
he's going to play rook c8 and he's
going to cause you well at least to get
a little bit defensive minded yeah but I
strongly encourage people to study the
Hedgehog from both the white and black
side it really
it's going to be worth points to you one
day trust me on that one and I actually
like to play both sides of the hedgehog
it was like one of those variations that
well excuse me for patting myself on the
back but I played really well and one of
my finest wins ever is I was playing
Grandmaster Yan Tim on and at the time
yuan Timmons playing for the World
Championship with Anatoly Karpov I was
black and a hedgehog and I took him out
cold like that was just like like this
is one of those games where it's the
total crush you know this was the 28th
did not think everybody's happy kind of
game but I used all of the motifs that
are common in hedgehogs and got him
really really nicely but there was there
was some serious errors going back and
forth and that first half-dozen moves as
you both were just kind of unaware of
the opportunities against you he just
said yeah you're prepared if you play E
for oh wow okay yeah and I once that
crushed myself I was on the on the wrong
side I was wrong put it just in that
position that you could have had that
your opponent could have achieved
against you Julian my opponent my Tony
miles achieved a position like this
against me I was on the white side of
such a position
where
I got somehow somehow my my pawns were I
had space but it was like they were
fixed that my pawns were rigid and when
the bishop came to b7 there was a
shocking move I think I was castled okay
so let's just say let's say a six
I'd say castles and something very bad
happened like b6 it's a king h1 and
let's say Bishop e7 so something very
bad happened to me I got a position like
this very similar to this and I didn't
think I was doing so bad like I was
doing okay and then there was this
really bad move that happened to me it
was like I I got hit with something that
I couldn't do much against the threat
like in this particular position we can
all see yeah exactly where you know or
or maybe it was like Queen e5 and he got
in g5 as well right and I had and you
know I got a position where like
suddenly
yeah yeah the Queen was like ah d5 it
was like in the middle of the board
suddenly there was like this Bishop d6
is coming and God knows maybe I ended up
with like like a bishop on g1 and he had
total domination of all the dark sources
like it was nightmarish I lost a game
but boy did I learn a very valuable
lesson and I was really in even in this
moment I was over appreciating my own
control of the center when it was like
his pieces were like crawling all over
me you know like ah you know so it was a
good lesson and this Knight d4 Bishop c5
is a is a nice one
well thank you all for coming to these
evenings lecture